i feel you're i'm a huge fan of your
work and i think one of the things
that you specialize in if
uh if and see if you agree is you're
very good
at blending tension
with comedy you have a very good ear
for just how to get that mix it's a very
hard thing to do
um but i've loved that you've done it
the way you've done it in all your
movies and now
i believe that you're that's what you're
accomplishing with truth seekers is to
try and get a nice blend of
it's humor but it's also the you feel
like the stakes are real
and there are moments of real horror is
that fair
did he lose me or did i lose him yeah
absolutely i mean oh good
kind of um you froze completely on my
end i think it's the
the our connection yeah it was really
funny
on my end because it looked like i just
asked you the stupidest question you've
ever heard
because i i asked you this question i
thought was pretty decent and you just
stared at me for um like five minutes
and i thought wow i just dare you
diamonds really pissed at me for
complimenting his ability to blend
comedy with horror and tension
so if you're angry tell me now i no i
i'm
i'm glad you think so i mean really it's
about
not when you with something like horror
you just don't make fun of the horror
you keep the horror intact it's very
easy to send up
anything which is sort of genre-based
sci-fi horror it's easy to make fun of
it because it requires us to
to suspend our disbelief and if you just
fold your arms and go that's ridiculous
you can spoof it or make fun but if you
just kind of let the comedy happen
adjacent to the horror then
you can have your cake and eat it you
know so that's kind of our philosophy
with true seekers which is a
sort of paranormal investigation comedy
it's nick's show really nick frost is
the
is is the main guy in it and i crop up
as his boss
um now and again but um yeah that's uh
that's our kind of always been our mo
really is is
don't don't take the easy route you know
yeah well
it's one of the things i remember uh i
we re-watched
i've watched hot fuzz several times uh
with my son
he's a massive fan of yours and we've
watched it several times and
and one of the things that i really
marvel at is it's
so funny and the comedy is so well done
but the stakes are high and my heart is
racing the whole time because you don't
condescend to do the action as
comedy it's real action oh sure yeah
absolutely
because otherwise it would be it
wouldn't work as well you know yes uh
and we love those movies we wouldn't we
weren't seeking to make fun of
of the american action film it was an
absolute love letter to it so it would
be silly to
do anything but try and be one of those
things you know right
right uh nick frost i know that you guys
have been friends
forever this started with you before
either of you had made it
and long before sean of the dead in your
20s you guys were hanging out together
probably i mean what were you doing what
were the two of you
doing to entertain yourselves and
and and to sort of let your imaginations
go
well we were sharing a flat together in
north london and um
we had very little uh in the way of
possessions we had a gas heater
on top of which was a combo television
uh vhs uh recorder and we would watch
episodes of the x-files seasons one and
two as it was then it was about 95
96 and um and also on the weekends we go
ghost hunting which was our code really
for
sitting in my run of five and getting
blazed in the countryside
okay so your search for the paranormal
involved you and nick frost sitting in a
car
uh and doing some kind of recreational
drug
exactly and the the paranormal thing was
seeing how many cheetos we could eat in
half an hour which would be
an unbelievable amount you know i are
normal levels of glutton
simon i suspect that many great ghosts
napoleon abraham lincoln queen victoria
contacted you guys but you were too
stoned
[Laughter]
yeah yeah whatever yeah whatever gandhi
whatever
we're busy
we have a uh we have a clip here from
truth seekers
that we're going to show right now
anything we need to know to understand
this scene
i think this is um as as nick's boss in
the show i kind of
tasked them he's basically a satellite
repair engineer with a new partner
and um he's sort of running a ghost um
hunting
um um business out of the back of his
van
and i'm sending him off to various
places and i i know where i'm sending
him you know these are the kind of
places so this is me tasking
gus with um going to a haunted
a formerly haunted hotel i think all
right let's take a look at this uh
clip from truth seekers listen can we
not have another day like yesterday
relax it's not like every place we go is
going to be haunted
sorry did you say haunted i did yes
britain's most haunted
three-star hotel the portland beacon and
i thought that might uh pique your
interest gus it's nothing but a cheap
tourist draw believe me i've
i've looked into it thorough as ever
that is why you are my number one
installer guest
and you mister ah my number
28. nope not bad
and we're back you and i didn't actually
see the clip
they'll slice that in because wasn't it
good
yeah brilliant um
i will get the word out on truth seekers
because uh
as i've as i've told you many times i'm
a massive fan of your work
uh you're uh enormously talented uh
gentlemen and i'm
very happy that these great things keep
happening for you you know god bless you
well it's
it's lovely to see you i was um i was
talking to someone the other day about
uh
it's been a while since we were how's
andy doing is he around
what's happening with him you know
what's so funny he he's here
uh he was here and we were he was
shooting with me uh but
um then he took off be i said look well
i'm gonna go do some interviews he's
like well then i'm out of here
he took off so enjoying the good life
somewhere if you can in quarantine it's
really focused us on our priorities this
pandemic that's for sure
yeah yeah uh all right well truth
seekers
truth seekers is available to stream on
amazon prime
video uh starting tomorrow and uh
whenever you and your good friend nick
frost do anything i'm down for it so i'm
very excited for this project
and uh thank you buddy thank you so much
for doing this what time is it where you
are by the way
it is just approaching 11 o'clock in the
evening here
okay and is the american election over
yet it would be great if you were a
couple of days ahead of us and you could
tell us what happened
oh i do i know and it's it's incredible
you won't believe it
okay uh just finished my interview with
uh simon pegg the only man who knows
what happens uh next tuesday hey simon
thank you no spoilers don't worry no
spoilers
no spoilers no spoiler actually people
would take a spoiler alert on this one
but um
thank you so much always a joy to talk
to you
and he's frozen again at the end you too
buddy you take care
simon they're really can you hear me it
really was a great moment where i asked
you a question and you just
you just stared at me and it but you're
frozen
but it really did look like you were
ricky gervais and i had said the wrong
thing